veamos si podemos encontrar el área del
paralelogramo y como siempre te invito a
que pongas pausa el vídeo y que lo
intentes solamente recuerda que el área
del paralelogramo se calcula como a es
igual a la base del paralelogramo por la
altura del paralelo gramo entonces área
es igual a base por altura que el lado
del padre le logramos se puede
considerar como la base podemos imaginar
que uno de estos dos lados lo será
cierto
podemos considerar que este lado será la
base entonces cuál es la longitud de
este lado observa que estamos estamos
ubicados en la dirección vertical vamos
de igual a 5h igual a menos 7 por lo
tanto este lado tiene longitud de 12
tenemos cinco unidades sobre el eje de
las equis y siete unidades bajo el eje
de las x lo cual suma dos unidades
entonces bueno podemos contar 12
es 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
así que esta es nuestra base así que
podemos decir que vas es igual a 12 y
ahora a que podemos considerar la altura
podemos ver que este lado puede ser la
altura entonces la altura es igual a 4
tal vez resulta un poco contraintuitivo
porque cuando hablamos de altura
pensamos en qué tan alto es algo pero
puedes imaginar hacer una rotación esta
figura tal que este lado la base esté
digamos sobre el suelo y la altura sea
la altura en el sentido tradicional de
la palabra entonces h es igual a 4 la
altura es igual a 4 y ahora ya salió
directo verdad porque el área será igual
a 12 que es la longitud de nuestra base
por la altura es decir por 4 lo cual es
igual a 12 por 4 48 por lo tanto el área
es 48 unidades cuadradas y ya está el
área del paralelogramo es igual a 48